Our CNN
political analyst, a New York Times
senior political correspondent,
and of course, Trump
biographer Maggie Haberman is there
and she joins us now by phone.
Maggie, obviously,
you heard the president's speech.
We did not take it here live.
What did you make of what he told
his supporters
compared to
how he was acting
when he was here in Florida
earlier today?
It's interesting, Kaitlan,
there were two things
that were striking about this speech.
Number one
is that he's going through,
at least for part of it,
a pretty dry recitation
of what
you're going to hear
from him and his team,
which is his claims
and a misstatement
of the Presidential Records Act,
that he was entitled
to keep these documents
that, you know,
no one else has been prosecuted
for doing what he did.
Prosecutors obviously
say that he chose things
that were among the nation's
most important classified material.
That's one thing that was striking.
But the other that was striking
is his delivery.
He made such a show in Miami
being seen at the restaurant for
which is something of a landmark
in Miami.
And, you know,
mingling with people
and talking to people,
very low energy tonight, very flat
delivery and spent
no time hanging out with the crowd
or sort of basking in their glow
afterwards,
turned on appeal
and walked back inside the Bedminster.
And so I think
this is going to be reality
going forward.
It's going to be him
defending himself
and offering up this claim
that he had the right
to do what he did,
which, again, prosecutors
say is not true.
But it's mixed with real anger
at the situation
And Maggie, what does that say to you
about giving
I mean,
you know, Trump
better than almost anyone else,
as you reported on him
at length, any other reporter,
I should note.
What does it say to you
about how he's actually viewing
this privately compared
to that bravado and bluster
we saw at the restaurant?
Here in Miami?
What I hear,
Caitlin, is it goes it goes up and down.
But there are times where he is
incredibly angry.
I heard that he was really mad
for the 90 minutes after that.
He found out roughly around 7 p.m.
on Thursday night
that he had been indicted.
And then he, you know,
got it together, went to dinner with the.
I thought he was very angry
the next day when he saw the indictment.
He was especially rattled
by the photographs that were in the dark.
In the indictment,
he actually referenced the photographs,
some of them anyway,
from the stage tonight behind the podium.
But then he has moments
of almost ebullience.
And, you know, it's
hard for people around him to tell
what's genuine
versus him
trying to keep up, as you said,
that were part of more than the bravado.
It's also
just the facade that everything is fine
because that's so much of how he how he
stacking the books
Yeah.
Who did you see in the
in the crowd tonight in Bedminster?
Did anyone stand out to you?
Well, many people stood out,
but mostly
because it was just such an eclectic
group of people, said Gorka,
who worked in the Trump White House
and been one of the loudest defenders
sort of on the on the fringe
on the right.
Ed Costa, chairman
of the Republican Party.
Bernie Kerik, the former
NYPD commissioner
A number of different people.
Mike Lindell, the Mypillow CEO, you know,
Tommy Tuberville,
the senator
who is supposed to be there tonight.
But for the most part, Caitlyn
you know, these were the diehards.
These were people who
were asked
by Trump's staff to be here or,
you know, who loved the chance
to see the former president.
But there were not
names of
people who were in his administration
or even on his past
presidential campaign.
So you're looking at a very,
very different chief here.
Yeah.
And of course, it's telling
who he surrounds himself with.
Maggie,
you say it's clear
that he's determined
to fight these charges,
obviously in the court of public opinion.
A lot of questions
on what his legal strategy
actually in the courthouse looks like.
Does this remind you
in any way
of how he responded
to what is obviously
a very different situation
but also came with a lot of fallout,
which was the Access
Hollywood tape
that came around,
of course, the last time
he was running for president?
Very much so.
He has basically you know,
a few moves, Caitlyn,
that he does over and over again.
And we saw it for the first time
in his political life
when the Access Hollywood tape came out.
His impulse
you know, again,
was when a crowd of his supporters
had a mass on Fifth Avenue
in front of the Trump Tower
was to go down
and literally
immersed himself in the crowd.
I was there for
it was a really striking image.
And it was almost as if
he was giving himself a pep talk,
you know,
clapping his hands together
and getting himself
locked up
a bit of what we saw
similarly in Miami today,
that is the impulse
is to just sort of
immerse myself in the crowd.
But that's not what we saw
in the speech tonight.
Again,
this was a carefully written speech
by some of his advisers
because he's laying out
what what
resembles a legal argument,
but which is really about
the court of public opinion.
But he was
he was deflated as he was getting it
or seemed deflated.
But I do think, yes,
this as Bill
echoes his immediate reaction
on all of these moments,
is to surround himself
with his supporters
and beat them
both as a bully for his emotions
and also as a shield against what says
another
person he's surrounding himself with
is his codefendant.
Well, not
just moments
after they left
the courthouse here behind me today,
they were seen together
at that restaurant.
Obviously, the judge has said
they are not supposed
to discuss this case
except through attorneys.
Do you think that that is
actually something
that the president will abide by?
Caitlin, I think that, you know,
the former president as well as I do.
And I think that,
you know, that not being told
not to do something as often
and as it is for him to do something,
especially this by a person in authority.
So I think this is going to be
a real challenge.
You know, it is
it is invariably,
if they're talking
I suspect, going to be worked so
well now that
because he is the codefendant,
not a former president,
and he has a very different circumstance,
he also has not been arraigned
because he did not have local counsel.
He still has to go back to court
in two weeks.
But I think that, you know,
not talking about the case
with either Wolf now
or witnesses
or the government is expected
to produce a list to say
these are people Trump
should not be talking directly to,
only to a counsel related to the case.
It's going to be it's
going to be a Herculean task to get
an option
Yeah.
We'll see what that looks like.
Maggie Haberman from Bedminster
in New Jersey at the former
Presidents Club, thank you.
Joining us
now here in Miami, David Weinstein
a former assistant U.S.
attorney
from the Southern District of Florida
and also
former chief of public integrity
in the Justice Department
South Florida office.
One of the perfect people
to talk about all of this with.
We'll get back to
what the former president
is saying tonight in just a moment.
But what you saw today
happening in this courthouse behind us.
Do you believe that's the way
that anyone else would be treated?
Do you think he was treated differently?
Not for a second.
He was given special treatment,
the likes of which
I've never seen before.
Any other defendant charged
with that many violations.
Possessing that many top secret
classified documents,
then charged
with obstructing
justice, making false statements
and having another open
pending felony case
would have been hard
pressed for the government
not to ask for detention
and for that defendant
to be sitting behind bars
waiting to see
whether or not he'd get out.
This defendant was released
under virtually no conditions.
So you believe,
even though
the way the former president
and his legal team framed it,
which is that
they're being treated unfairly by
by the prosecution, by the courts here,
they're actually going out of their way
to accommodate him.
Absolutely. Bending over backwards.
The fact that he didn't get arrested
Friday morning,
where he was living in the dark hours
and brought before a magistrate judge
to make his initial appearance
on a sealed indictment.
That's what happens in the normal case.
So when you hear
what the former president
was saying tonight,
talking about the Espionage Act
and how that is
part of the charges that have been
that are part of this indictment,
he was had this quote
that was saying
that it's used for spies, for traitors.
But it's obviously
much more expansive than that.
What he's saying about it is incorrect.
Absolutely incorrect.
Look, it's
part of a larger
act, the Espionage Act,
and it covers people who had at one time
access to documents
because they had clearance
to have those documents.
And then they took those documents
from a place
where they should have been
under secure quarters
and either held them or
kept them somewhere else
or share them with other people.
That's what
it is alleged that he has done.
It doesn't have to be a mail drop
where spy versus spy
meet each other somewhere
and hand over secret documents.
It's the improper
use and handling of classified documents.
And in this case, documents
that were alleged
to contain defense
and military secrets of our country
and that were stored in places
you know, he's there at the former club
or at his club tonight,
where we also know
he took boxes of documents up
to Bedminster with him
when it comes to
what's next
and what a trial looks like here.
How fast do you think we could see
a trial potentially in this case?
It's not going to occur that quickly
in a regular case.
They move fast
here in the southern district.
Of Florida,
trial be set in a couple of months.
It'll be
perhaps continued a little bit, case
to be resolved in six to nine months.
But here you have security
clearances are needed for his counsel.
You're going to have motion practice.
You're going to have motions,
and undoubtedly you're going to end up
at the 11th Circuit
and requests
for continuance
to try and push this matter off
past the November election.
So in a case
that could normally be resolved
by March or April.
This one's going to drag out
at least until the summer.
Well, and of course, the question is,
does it happen
before the 20, 24 election?
We'll wait to see David Weinstein.
Of course,
you are the perfect person
to talk about this.
You've been
in that courthouse many times.
Thank you for joining us today.
You're welcome.